le théâtre montansier c'est avant tout
une histoire de femmes la première
marguerite brunet dit mademoiselle
montant c elle crée ce théâtre qui
prendra son nom inaugurée le 18 novembre
1777 parle de 16 c'est un théâtre qui
est la particularité d'être entre la
ville et la cour c'est ce qui fait sa
spécificité il est d'abord situer
géographiquement entre la ville de
versailles et le parc du château
et il accueille au sein du public à la
fois des membres de la cour et des
versaillais qui viennent assister une
programmation extrêmement riche
près de 180 objets retrace l'histoire de
ce lieu peut être moins connu que
l'opéra royal ou le petit théâtre de la
reine des documents d'époque issus des
collections de la ville dont une lettre
écrite durant la révolution
dans cette lettre au moment où la
montansier est en prison elle essaie de
se justifier auprès dès révolutionnaires
et elle va inventer prétendre qu'elle a
était révolutionnaire avant la lettre en
accueillant les parisiennes au théâtre
de versailles durant les journées
d'octobre le 20e siècle est lui aussi
marqué par une femme marcelle
tassencourt qui le dirigera avec son
mari thierry monnier de 1961 à 1992
marcel tassencourt était à la fois
comédienne metteur en scène elle a été
vraiment une passeuse de théâtre à
versailles en étant à la fois la
directrice du théâtre elle a enseigné au
conservatoire et la forme et un certain
nombre d'élèves qui sont aujourd'hui
assez assez célèbre certains comédiens
d'autres noms comme françois de mazières
l'actuel maire de versailles ou bien
encore muriel mayette qui dirige
la villa médicis à rome le théâtre
montansier se dévoile à travers ses
programmations ses succès ses scandales
ou encore ces rénovations
un anniversaire fêté aux archives
communales de la ville